il y a deux monuments sur sur balzac à
tour celui de 1889 et celui ci qui est
de la main de françois sicard et qui
intervient dix ans plus tard soit pour
le centenaire de la naissance de balzac
et qui a été inaugurée sur la maison
natale de l'écrivain sauver en 1941
après un incendie qui ravage la rue
nationale à tours c'est le seul monument
qui reste aujourd'hui au château de
sachets la statue de balzac réalisé par
paul fournier en 1889 a connu elle un
sort funeste
elle sera déboulonnée par les allemands
en 1941 pour être fondue et faire des
canons monumental balzac présente
l'histoire de ces monuments l écrivain
projets avortés monuments disparus
une plongée au 19e siècle celui de la
statue à manille
on veut des édifices publics de grands
hommes dans l'espace public donc la
ville de tours se veut devancer paris ce
pour quoi elle va demander à paul
fournier est inaugurée dès 1889 son
monument à balzac et la société des gens
de lettres pour la ville de paris veut
elle aussi son monument à balzac
elle va demander henry chaput qui
décèdent puis emile zola qui devient le
président de la société des gens de
lettres demande à rodin et cette mission
va l'occuper pendant sept années de sa
vie
une statue qui sera refusé pour celles
plus académique de fallières pourtant
balzac restera le symbole de l'audace et
de la modernité de rodin le sculpteur va
s'émanciper totalement des acquis des
akyé académique du 19e siècle de
représenter l écrivain tel qu'il est
pour donner finalement une image
vraiment nouvelle et l'inédite esquisse
étude les fonds d'atelier des sculpteurs
offre un regard différent sur l'écrivain
qui n'aimait pas son image monumental
balizac est à découvrir au musée des
beaux-arts jusqu'au 2 septembre